okay we legit have a minute so hey vsf's  courtney i hear you have a question oh  you guys look so great  hi drew this is my daughter kylie  hi kylie uh we have a question we're  here in new jersey and fall has hit us  pretty quickly with the cold weather  so i'm not a fan of flipping my closet  what's something from the summer you're  taking into your fall wardrobe  oh you know what i have to tell you like  i do not look good in puffy clothing i  don't know what it is but i  just look like the michelin man like  giant human  stack of tires so i'm all about layering  take those looks  take a shirt you like layer it with a  sweater a bigger jacket like wear five  things on top instead of that one puffer  at least that's what i have to do  thank you so much and you guys are so  beautiful  and everybody looks so great in the wall  i love all the doggies today  [Music]  you